Now that you have been introduced to data types.
Let's look at the many options of visual encodings that we have.
Simply put, visual encodings are mapping from data to display elements.
The visualization that we saw before shares the correlation between income per
person and life expectancy, in many different countries.
This graphic is rich with visual encodings.
Let's take a look at some of those visual encodings now.
Life expectancy is encoded visually along the y axis,
while spending per person is encoded along the x axis.
For our data visualization this means that countries that are located in
the top-right corner of the graph, like Qatar, had a high income per person and
high life expectancy, the opposite would be true for
the countries in the lower left of the graph.
Position is considered a planar variable because it locates points in space.
It's probably one of the most prominent visual encodings that you'll see in
data visualization.
And it's also a display element that we can perceive with great accuracy.
So we know that position can be good for encoding two variables, but what do we
do if we want to visualize higher dimensions of the data, say a third variable.
Well, we could visualize a third variable in the third dimension, so
along the z axis here.
However, 3D models are generally poorly perceived by our eyes,
as it's more difficult to make quantitative comparisons between points.
For example, I'm not so
sure which of these two points has a greater y value, or height.
So we need some other way of encoding some third variable for
our data visualization,
fortunately, we have some other display elements that we can use instead.
We can use what are called retinal variables to encode additional variables for
our data set, size is an example of a retinal variable, and
it's particularly good for ordered data.
Going back to our world health data visualization,
we can see that population is encoded by the size of each of the circles, or
more precisely by the area of each point.
In combination with color, the size attribute makes some
countries more recognizable such as India, China and the United States.
Size and color hue,
which we just saw in the visualization, are both examples of retinal variables.
And if we wanted to,
we can even encode additional variables and these other retinal variables.
Size, orientation, and
color saturation are particularly effective for order data.
However, it maybe difficult to perceive quantitative differences using these
visual encodings.
The perceived value difference between say light blue and
light light blue isn't so obvious.
These other retinal variables such as color hue, shape, and
texture, are great for encoding nominal variables.
For our gap minder visualization,
we can see that color hue encodes the geographical regions of the world.
This choice of color makes it easier to compare income and
life expectancy across developed and less developed countries of the world.
The last variable we need to address is time.
Now, time isn't a static display element like color, size or position.
Instead time is animated through individual frames in our visualization.
The quick succession of these frames shows change in life expectancy,
income per person, and population over time.
It is the remarkable and engaging aspect of this visualization, and we
will learn how to incorporate this type of dynamic visualization in lesson four.
Now that you've seen one example of how map data to display elements,
we`re going to see if you can do it for two more visualizations.